south africa is heading for its own
version of the arab spring that's the
warning from former president tabon
becky he says current head of state
cyril ramaphosa has failed to tackle
poverty unemployment and inequality it's
a rare attack by baikey on the
leadership of the governing african
national congress why is he speaking up
now
this is inside story
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to the programme i'm
bernard smith
it was an unprecedented outspoken attack
on his own party and its leader tarbon
bakey warns that one day south africa is
going to explode the former president
was speaking at a memorial for a veteran
member of the governing african national
congress
and baikey who in 1999 succeeded nelson
mandela the first democratically elected
president warned of widespread civil
unrest comparable to the arab spring he
says south africa is facing
unsustainable levels of poverty and
unemployment and blames current
president cyril ramaphosa and his
government for failing to address the
legacy of apartheid you can't have so
many people's
unemployed
so many people poor
people faced with this lawlessness i'm
talking about
faced with the leadership in which they
see these agency people one after
another are called corrupt
one day is going to explode
ramaposa is a former freedom fighter who
was once jailed by the apartheid
government he took office in 2018
succeeding jacob zuma whose term was
mired by scandals corruption
mismanagement of millions of dollars in
taxpayers money
ramaphosa's presidency has faced several
challenges his response to the kovid 19
pandemic was applauded but his party was
accused of mishandling millions of
dollars in relief funds
most recently he is embroiled in a
scandal known as farmgate ramaphosa is
accused of corruption in connection with
a theft of around four million dollars
in cash from his farm with a criminal
complaint filed against him for alleged
money laundering kidnapping and the
concealing of a crime
well let's now go to our guests all in
south africa in durban dakota la huerta
he's the anc national spokesman in cape
town we have musi maimani he's the
founder of this one south africa
movement and a former leader of south
africa's opposition and in johannesburg
william germaidy is an associate
professor at the school of governments
at the university of waters round thank
you all for joining us can i ask you
first dakota is tabo and becky right
when he says south africa is ready to
explode
luke
chapenberg is right in the fact that
there's no government that leaves
existence so
we become a government because you can
provide
for our people
today according to statistics south
africa
over 25 million south africans live
without food
daily
and today in south africa more than 5
million
undocumented foreign nationals
who are not
documented by our
homophrasis and that creates a problem
okay thank you
okay so uh musi what do you think south
africa ready to explode as ambaki says
certainly i
i hold the view that the anc like any
other liberation movement have come to a
point where they've mismanaged the
economy leading
lines and lines of unemployed south
africans
literally we live in a country where the
majority of citizens are living below
the upper poverty line and youth
unemployment now constitutes close to
about two-thirds so two-thirds of young
people here cannot find a job
so given those sets of circumstances
without the prospects of a tomorrow
president is correct in the summation
that south africa is facing an explosion
where i would urge for him to go further
is the reasons that come through that
have been part of his own party the
mismanagement of economic infrastructure
and ultimately the lack of policy
direction amongst the government has
brought us to this particular point
william what do you think has prompted
tarbon becky to speak out
now think you know we are if you look at
our environment if you could compare
where um you know the arab spring just
you know the months
ahead of the arab springs we cast
exactly the same environment now i mean
the first thing it really is a failure
total failure of the state
uh to deliver then a social order
breakdown in the country law a rule of
law and order a breakdown and then
combined with the biggest financial
crisis in south africa in generations
course of course uh by the coven uh the
financial crisis uh or the corporate
minds related financial crisis and now
the impact
of the russia um ukraine war and then
you link it with witness management of
the states and as managements of the
company's um
economy now you combine that and then
you know um
high the highest levels of unemployment
recorded in any other
emerging market and then you combine it
with something else and there's
something else that recombines in south
africa really is you have an elite um
who's in charge but who seems to be not
have the ideas or seems to be socially
distanced left in a bubble
who seems not to understand
happening because the social distance
between the governing party and nature
leads and ordinary citizens who are
struggling who are struggling uh you
know it's too wide and so there's
unresponsiveness from the governor's and
then linked to that is also an arrogance
uh by the elite so again what happens
then if you got that um it's really an
explosive
um
situation particularly also when the
governing party try to continue as
business as usual
in the biggest crisis certainly um in a
living memory i mean we've seen it last
last week for example um interest rates
were
increased um you know across the economy
the state has been increasing uh on
rates and services fees but yet the
state is not delivering
dakota william there talks about an
elite living in a bubble a bubble has
the anc
lost the confidence of south africans is
it uh
does it elite not understand what needs
to be done has it been in power for too
long
good no
dlc
in itself does not exist
on its own politics is because it's an
instrument of liberation
the anc is not a narrow nationalist
organization
we are not a nazi or a facility
we defend our people
and that's how we exist
and and you know
south africa with its complexities
in terms of national engagement
it's a country that meets the african
national congress it's a country that
needs something like anc
to exist because
on our own we're not like china
we're in china but we're not like
germany west germany
yeah what exists out of multiple
origin of nationalities
any non-nationalist organization would
not survive in south africa
from us
it needs to understand that presidency
so far with all our weaknesses
we we are ready to self-correct we are
ready to improve
and we are ready to find a better life
for all south africans and all people
of humanity and thank you that's how we
exist
thank you
uh dakota there defends the legacy of
the anc acknowledges its weaknesses but
you've said uh cyril ramaphosa should
resign but would that make any
difference in in the current
circumstances
well it would start the direction of the
country in the right way i think
president ramaphosa and his government
have proven that they are unfit i think
we need
a fresh reset in south africa a new
government that is led by competent
south africans whose focus is on the
future of this country the key failures
aren't just in economic mismanagement
the nc in and of itself is
delivering a situation where 80 percent
of our learners in this country
are high in schools that are
dysfunctional which means that the
long-term trajectory of south africa is
hard furthermore that it's the same
agency that's allowed corruption to
thrive certainly under president zuma
and it has continued under president
ramaphosa who he himself has now been
allegedly been embroiled in so whatever
emerges out of the new leadership that
mr dakota is talking about
self-correction will be a compromise to
preserve status quo and lead no one to
jail so if you really want to reset
south africa we need a new leadership we
need a new coalition and we need an
economic vision that says how can south
africa not only inter-trade within
africa but compete globally with other
markets in recovery to a post-covet
universe and furthermore to ensuring
that youth unemployment does not become
the trend okay william after the
well-documented rampant corruption of
the of the zuma years ramaposa was
supposed to be a new broom wasn't he
what's what's gone wrong
i think you know many south africans do
not understand that
you know the corruption
otherwise jacob zuma presidency was so
systemic
um i mean you know there was a
corruption not only of the states
corruption of policies corruption of
rhetoric of ideas
um
you know for procurement and also the
corruption of the party of the agency's
governing party now normally in
societies once you get that kind of
systemic corruption and jacob zuma was
there for 10 you know almost for a
decade we call it you know the lost
decades it takes at least another 10
years to get back to where he started
and that's normally you know where i
says in the kind of research i do
looking at other competitive developing
countries and you know how they got out
of corruption and when they got in into
corruption how long it takes to get out
of it um so and if you look at the
african situation you know since african
liberation movements is the end of
independence now that moment you know if
a country spends five or ten years
systemically corrupt is a party or a
state it takes about ten to two even in
some cases 20 years and then of course
we've seen in some countries and they've
never gotten out of the corruption um
where there's a zimbabwe and so on so
you can't get out of the state failure
if the governing party
is still there so what we need we need
to step down actually after the anc is a
governing party and get new people uh to
come in i mean that really is almost the
only way to renew the country the state
the society
and the country's culture
dakota not much confidence from our
other guests in in the anc's capability
to manage this we've had the final
findings of the three year inquiry to
state capture presented it revealed
endemic corruption as we've talked about
ramapose has promised a plan to
implement the report's recommendations
in four months time does the anc realize
how critical this is for the party and
the government
indeed were critical this year's
like i said before
we are an instrument of liberation there
is a people
as the nc worker on
corruption as you can own corrupt
elements
who are very clear between our position
that those who are cut out are not part
of our money
because our money was to liberate
people
and african in particular from the
bondages
dakota if i may interrupt you
briefly i don't think many people
dispute the anc's revolutionary
credentials in terms of ending apartheid
but with youth unemployment the highest
in the world with record levels of
poverty and equality the anc is failing
to deliver those now isn't it it's
revolutionary credentials accepted but
now it needs to deliver for
indeed
today
correct we need to deliver what we are
supposed to deliver and the man's part
of it was the deal
with the epidemic problems of
unemployment
and unemployment it's a
manifestation of the anc failure to deal
with the issue of the colonial economic
structure
wherein minorities
who are mainly from european descent
are in charge of the economy and the
financial structure of our country
and i think as anc
we don't have to limit ourselves to a
point where we deal with scams of social
grants for people we need to get to a
point where we transform the
commanding heights of the economy
including the economic ownership of our
country
as well as the outlook
of who owns the economic country willing
we
william are you confident that sarah
ramaphosa cannot can come up with those
recommendations in in four months or is
that is the rot too deep
i think the rot is too deep um and it's
very difficult now because you know you
also understand that some of uh
president ramaphosa um is also not in
gulf
in the allegations of corruption around
what has happened at his farm there
was called here in south africa farm
gate and i think his focus now really is
in trying to
um you know to survive politically
survive um and death scandal within the
anc you know it's up for you for the
election at the end since december
conference so between now and the end of
the year when the answer is uh the
electoral councils take place i don't
think president ramaphosa will be
focusing on the crisis neither sadly the
anc will be focusing on the crisis on
the one hand uh president obama borza is
going to be focused trying to campaign
to get re-elected and to try to clear
his name um
until december and on the other hand
what we're seeing in the country and
maybe there is what is generating so
much hopelessness um and anger in the
country is that the agencies really is
focusing on his own internal battles
from within and even the conversations
that the anc has the conversations is so
far from from the crisis and the ancient
stalking and ancient leaders are talking
uh blaming apartheid blaming colonialism
but the agency has been in power for
over three decades you have to imagine
over three decades the anc you know the
agency is in charge of the status it's
in charge of the economies in charge of
the country's policy whether it's
domestic or foreign policy uh you know
no one after three decades can still
blame um the past but
one if one has had as a party such a
monopoly control
over the state since the end of the
party
moosey i know you've written recently
that south africa african leaders
actually should look to what's happened
in sri lanka
that in sri lanka
was a revolution against
elected representatives and similarly in
south africa you had violence last year
that might be a taste of what's to come
that makes it different from the arab
spring and that was a revolution against
dictatorships is democracy letting
people down in south africa
no i think that i think the economic
circumstances are often hard in this
country
but what i'm starting to realize at this
point in time is that
as the maturity
of the electorate start to realize
that even though they exercise the vote
and the promise that the anc puts
forward of this so-called renewal is not
occurring
their frustrations are bubbling over
into the streets
and i would argue that their
frustrations will soon bubble over to
the state because the nc as a liberation
movement is no different than any other
one in the rest of the continent at
first they garner the state they
mismanage it and then they find creative
ways to stay in power so projectively
you realize that the future of the anc
is not different to that of zanu-pf in
that these could become liberation
movements that start to infiltrate the
judiciary uh frustrate media
independence and ultimately obfuscate
election results so we have to work hard
in the period now so that democracy is
maintained in this country or we face
the real prospect of outside interests
that can motivate and disillusion youth
to be able to create this instability in
the country we'll come back to that
subject in a second uh but dakota what
do you think cyril ramaphosa ramaphosa's
chances are of winning re-election as
the anc leader later this year
as anc
the future of any leader or any position
depends upon the basic structures of the
signature branches
for now no leader is guaranteed
any relation for now no leader is
guaranteed
any
stay in the party
what happens that
any leader would have done
what is supposed to have been done in
terms of the last conference resolutions
the last conference police positions
and and and once that leader
is determined by structures with the nc
he will come back and this is not
difficult for president developers to
come back once branches of the ncaa come
further okay with his performance
with his ability and capability as a
leader
to deliver the manager
okay
william thank you william just help us
understand the day-to-day living
circumstances of ordinary south africans
at the moment like in many developing
world countries people live day to day
what they earn that day is what they
spend on food at the end of that day
there's no weekly shop hedging against
inflation that sort of thing how are
ordinary south africans surviving at the
moment
i mean i think you know because this is
the biggest financial crisis um at least
in the post-democratic era but certainly
this may be the biggest financial crisis
um since the end of the second world war
um in south africa i mean if you think
about the numbers two thirds of all
young people are unemployed if you think
of you know another number just in terms
of adults being here
almost 50 percent of adult south
africans are unemployed um we've now
getting fuel prices because of the
impact of the russian ukraine war fuel
prices traffic of
sky high most people take i mean most
people i just just give you example i
mean about 30 40 percent of people's um
income at the lower end
of spectrum in south africa spent on
transport so all those money goes there
we may even have now potentially the
highest inflation
rate um in you know the post um
uh apartheid you know very very typical
space then you know a public health
state health system um because the state
has failed has absolutely collapsed if
you go to public hospital now the joke
is um in south africa you go there to
die um public education systems schools
and the townships um if we compare you
know let's just say mathematics compared
to our emerging markets and even our
african um counterparts um we're
certainly among the worst um um if you
compare
with
our public education with other
countries and then of course we've got
over 800 state-owned entities certainly
any emerging markets um
our
so these are most um state-owned
companies uh yeah um if you compare to
our other emerging markets but almost 90
percent of all of those state-owned
companies have all failed i mean they
bank up um in the last decade just
a 1.5 trillion iran has been used to
bail out just states uh uh owned
companies this is a real crisis i mean
it is as i say the biggest
financial crisis in living memory okay
moosie isn't the problem for you that
the politicians that are capitalizing on
the circumstances william talked about
are the ones from the populist end of
the spectrum you've had two new parties
making big gains in municipal elections
that run an anti-migrant platforms you
have julius malema of the economic
freedom
fighters who went round with people into
restaurants demanding to know if they
employed foreign workers uh the other
day they are the politicians making in
roads here whereas people like you who
want to try and bring races together are
struggling against that populist wave
yeah i think globally we went through
that wave and you described periods that
occurred even pre-covet and maybe to
some of the time we saw in the us what
that meant we saw even some of the
french elections and all of those all so
the global phenomena was in place but i
would argue william that in fact we are
now getting to a point where as more and
more people realize
that actually the rational
center argument has to be restored back
into south africa there are more people
now trying to coalesce around the center
and i would argue the case that come
2024 you'll see that in place because
the plans for majority of south african
citizens they realize if if they all
blame the immigrants as sometimes even
the anc wants to do you would have had a
far greater growth but we are now
describing six five or five five to ten
percent i want to say this equally so
and this is a very important point is
that what the greater disappointment
with the anc has been is that we've been
through periods in the past where we
actually did see economic growth where
we did see infrastructure being built in
a democratic era and that has all
dissipated nancy is not going to be able
to redo it and that is what we still
need we need that five percent gdp
growth we need that infrastructure
rebuild and i think citizens like myself
and many others are now starting to form
that coalition in the center that will
be able to bring about that middle
ground that central vote to be able to
bring about the change in 2024 okay very
last very quick answer to the uh to the
independent here at the table william do
you think the anc can recover in time
for the national elections or do part
people like uh mumsey have a chance
um you know my sense is this is the end
uh the decline of the anc you know in
africa if you look at
our african history outside africa also
by about a third decade um you know the
generations um that voted for the aliens
for liberation parties and if the
liberation party fail um they quit uh
voting um for their party so we we at
that stage now um it it does appear i
think um really should be um the anc
will um drop below 50 percent
if it's lucky it would be you know
mid-forties um if um president ramaphosa
is not ahead of the anc very likely to
the mid thirties and every anc drop
below the mid-30s it won't be able to
put a coalition um together um but if
it's sort of in the late or the mid-40s
it should be able to put a coalition
together but it will never be able i
think to govern on its own anymore all
right we are gentlemen unfortunately out
of time but thanks to all our guests to
dakota luite to musi maimani and to
william germaidy
thank you too for watching you can see
the program again anytime by visiting
our website aljazeera.com and for more
debate go to our facebook page that's
facebook.com forward slash aj inside
you can also join the conversation on
twitter we are at aj inside store from
me bernard smith and the whole team here
bye for now
[Music]